Breen's Joey COGO beers here mad flavors
world my co-host skinny finis listening
I haven't even [ __ ] done nothing yet
we're here to thank you people for all
the donations and if you still want to
[ __ ] and drop a nickel or a dime the
button is still available keep [ __ ]
tapping we're almost dead but no I'm
saying thank you from the bottom of my
heart that's why I do these things for
you people this episode then you're
gonna see is [ __ ] smoking like do
this I do that it's a surprise but I'm
here my main man and this episode is
sponsored my son [ __ ] bombers
look at the size of this thing here I'm
gonna get bicep just picking this up
this is what they gave put Tommy kicked
I put the tool away and pick this [ __ ]
up go away thank you very much for
watching mad flavors well your Alyssa be
[ __ ] you do [ __ ]
it's a beautiful Sunday morning here in
California winner Joey cocoa Diaz glad
flavors world walking around the
beautiful farmers market look at those
beautiful tomatoes that's a tomato right
bit more on the cob let's taste this
cantaloupe let's see what's really
grabbing
it's a beautiful enjoy comedy
the farmers market staying black baby
eating some fruit making a happen I'll
give thee zombies look at this guy died
and came back to life it's all about it
some some sightseeing looking at the
people look at this guy getting votes in
he doesn't get paid he's getting votes
then what the hell you're doing out here
Sunday after they were doing same what
are you gonna do I'm gonna go break his
balls a little bit what's happening
everything I can
I'm Joey Diaz I can't sign them because
I want felonies I got felonies I can't
[ __ ] well here's the deal I'm from
Jersey all right North Bergen New Jersey
I bought you a pencil you're the man
that's the last of Mohicans that's Sammy
the Bulls neighborhood good you over
here you over you hustle he's closed our
East Coast I've taken signatures on a
Sunday like mad at labor we're out here
putting it together I'll let you do your
thing I would sign it you get a couple
of dollars but I got the felonies they
do a background check you're not gonna
get you a couple of dollars you know I
love you stay black
this poor [ __ ] guy get the signatures
out there on the Lord today what are you
gonna do you insane mad flavors world
Joey Coco Diaz coming at you from Los
Angeles California let the pigeons loose
baby
laughs that's how we do it [ __ ] will
see with prices like a fool some cat
treats
Terrence
I gotta give him a Catholic labour
that's what they like
let's see what the cat food of dr. 47
cents and I got coupons that's how we
roll here at Ralph's Matt flavors well
Joey Coco did Serena this [ __ ]
maggots looking around me with the
camera what are you taping not you [ __ ]
don't mind your [ __ ] business
Joey Diaz here about to go into my one
of my favorite Chinese restaurants the
Chinese [ __ ] deli in North
Hollywood I've been coming here for
about a year and this place is the [ __ ]
you understand me especially for lunch
they give you the [ __ ] soup the
noodles the entree the white rice the
egg roll and the sauna for like 550
becoming a CEO Pancho yarmulkes in here
you know this is the [ __ ] joint the
either you know I'm saying Matt flavor
here I'm inside with my beautiful wife
but the filete was the second phase of
life in the food services service the
ambience the wide-open kitchen as they
call the year of our fresco elephant
this is what they do that Tokyo in the
power 40 areas does you ready
busted you ask people who positively
like it
but try the deli they give it to you
straight up that's like this right there
that's Chinese food right there right
before I got the [ __ ] look at that
beauty I got my egg roll experiment
whatever that is homemade shrimp I see
the sourcing under rice who is better
than me
Matt flavours world thank you for
watching the food and dishes [ __ ] you
know what you know me when I'm not on
stage I've got a yoga I'm not doing
jumping jacks I'm not driving beeping at
people you know what I'm doing and
hanging out with the cats and tonight
I'm going to show you how we do it with
the laser beams of [ __ ] hit the Lights
my a stroke
go get it this thing grab it come on
let's go that's a beauty right there
come on three more let's go here we go
here we go there you go she needs to
spend about ninety two more times
this one's likes to eat and nap and the
answer those keep it going that's how we
doing it that's the other one that's it
see now since he's gonna get it where
you going [ __ ] hurry up bring it back
with her back with everybody that [ __ ]
go [ __ ] bring it back to Lulu this my
Lulu this she is what solutions but this
[ __ ] some reason I guess what then the
second flavor here but Harry one did his
brother this is the other side of it you
see how he's signed easy
this is his twin brother is not Siamese
it took quite the eight generations of
other Asian cats and put them all in
look this guy could rip your heart out
with one swipe his [ __ ] facts could
cure he was loved they all loved the
common denominator
leave a made man just said that whenever
he comes over here he notices all my
cats are really cool listen man I gave
these cats so much love they want food
is the only way they could be and these
[ __ ] came from pure Killa stock
the father was a savage I will put a hit
on the farmers I caught myself
the real game the common denominator
with these animals
this is all they would this got a little
what the [ __ ] to do Matt flavors will
give you animal luck that's all they
[ __ ] love and water in the trees
I will [ __ ] soldier great Bubba
[Music]